wonderful wonderful Copenhagen where did
I where did I put my bike up there is in
Copenhagen bikes wool the road
[Music]
there are more than just bike lanes here
there are bike only bridges and the
traffic lights they're timed for
bicyclists good worn with days short of
seven hours in the winter Danes like to
spend as much time as possible in their
parks but this is no ordinary Park it's
also a cemetery Copenhagen's assistant
cemetery is where you'll find the grave
of Rayder hands christian andersen this
nearby statue dedicated to andersen
story The Little Mermaid is Copenhagen's
most visited attraction but where are
all the tulips oops
tulips aren't Danish they're Dutch
one of the most popular open-air markets
here is Christian iya aka Freetown we're
pretty much anything goes okay kill the
camera all right how many Ounces you got
in here okay put it in the back all
right
scram Oh can't wait to dig into this
Danish funny thing is what we call it
Danish is actually Austrian mmm good
stuff
now when authentically Danish Danish is
actually called a smile as in snail want
coffee with that talk come to Copenhagen
smallest cafe located in the world's
smallest hotel be sure to book well in
advance the Central Hotel has just one
room now Copenhagen's Radisson Blu Royal
is considered the world's first designer
hotel credit goes to arm Jacobsen
considered one of Denmark's
finest architects his Swan and egg
chairs that helped define mid-century
modern are still here in the lobby this
is the egg that's the swamp Denmark also
gave us Lego and eco shoes hey let go my
echo excuse me I'm looking for a pair of
wooden clogs that's right clogs aren't
Danish they're Dutch the changing of the
gaurd happens every day at noon outside
amalienborg palace seat of the Danish
monarchy which dates back more than
thousand years here lives prince henrik
recently named the world's grumpiest
royal I'll tell you one thing he's got
it a lot better than the Royals who
supposedly lived here at kronborg castle
the setting for Shakespeare's Hamlet we
all know how that ended still grumpy now
Henrik middle Grendon is the world's
first offshore wind farm turbines like
these provide power to almost 40% of
Denmark it's a long way from the
windmills of old arrgh
those weren't Danish they're Dutch
Babbitt in any one the number one player
in the world is Denmark's Victor axel
Sedna your sir Victor how about a beer
Denmark's Carlsberg is home to the
largest collection of unopened beer
bottles all of them different in the
world twenty-two thousand five hundred
and fifty-eight make that twenty two
thousand five hundred fifty seven Tivoli
Gardens is the world's second oldest
amusement park
the world's oldest amusement park a
bokken is also in Denmark but that's
about 13 kilometers or eight miles away
and well it's been a long day
[Music]
you